hello everyone and welcome back to the
saint louis rapid and blitz tournament
the three days of rapid are over and now
we have two days of blitz um our first
nine rounds uh of uh blitz will be
played and then at nine more rounds of
blitz will be played but with callers
reversed and this is the first game that
we are going to show uh we've already
shown a game uh from the rapid section
where alireza uh played brilliantly
against nepo and he got a very nice
advantage right out of the opening but
it wasn't all that easy to convert that
and in the end even though he had a
winning position uh the game ended in a
draw but now this is from the blitz
section as it there you have it the
little b on the robot on the on the uh
right bottom
uh and it's uh again quite an impressive
game very quickly we run into a
completely new game and very quickly
things um start to go very very wrong
for one of the players so let's check it
out alireza has the wide pieces and he
opens with c4 he goes for the english
sorry about that uh jan replies with e5
grabs the center we have d3 knight to f6
and not knight to f3 we have knight to
c6
so the three knights are now developed
but now not knight to c3 rather pawn to
a3 stopping any bishop to b4 action in
the future and also just preparing to
strike on the queen side with b4 so jan
strikes in the center with d5 uh
captures captures and just pawn to e4
chasing away the knight knight to b6 and
now bishop to e2 both players prepare to
castle bishop to e7 we have castles
castles and now bishop to e3 so one
thing that you can notice about this
position is that
uh well your vast chest knowledge is
probably telling you that uh black has
nothing to worry about here uh the pawn
on d3 is a backward spawn it's it's a
weak pawn and if you if you don't push
it to d4 at some point it's gonna be a
problem and you are correct here if this
was a classical game of course all it is
i would never play this but it's a blitz
game so he plays it with uh pawn to f5
and now uh
expecting pawn to f4 uh alireza plays
pawn to b4 and this is now the idea if
f4 just bishop c1 to b2 alireza will
shift the bishop over to this diagonal
just give me a second i think meadow
wants to come in into the room
yeah he's a weird dude i asked him if he
wanted to go up he was like nah i'm just
going to stay down downstairs uh but now
you know
in the middle of the video he wants to
come up but okay i mean he is uh he's a
dog after all uh so okay b4 uh and jan
advances his pawn to f4 attacks the
bishop on e3 and uh there is a game
where a6 was played in this position but
f4 is a new move so now already as of
move 10 we have a completely new game
well it is a transfer the bishop back to
c1 and now he will play bishop to b2 and
uh employ the bishop on this long
diagonal we have a6 bion bishop to b2
and now bishop to f6 as the e5 pawn
might come under attack maybe some
knights to d tonight the c4 ideas and
then at some point the d4 should be
played so here knight b to d2 and now
jan doesn't wait to see what aleris that
will come up with he just plays pawn to
g5 now prepares g for maybe h5 g4 uh we
have h3 stopping g4 and now ian plays
bishop to e6 uh also uh maybe just g4 uh
captures captures develop the bishop
this way but jan uh says nope i'm going
to just develop bishop to e6 and now we
have rook to c1 uh queen to d6 and now
comes knight to b3 violet so which is a
great move uh but um yeah this is a
blitz game so of course players don't
have all that much time to
uh calculate uh the moves in the
position but as you guys are very much
interested in this position i will just
say it uh you know straight off uh d4 is
winning here for white and d4 is
unstoppable uh but i'm gonna show you
why it's why it's so fun uh of course
not reacting to d4 is out of the
question i mean now of course the d5 d
captures an e5 you do not want to see
those moves happen so let's say e
captures on d4 now e5 you give up
another pawn uh to free up the e for
square for your knight and then just
everything falls apart for black for
example knight captures on e5 knight e4
attacks the queen and the bishop so
first let's eliminate one more piece
bishop captures an f3 and now queen d8
we have to save our queen knight
captures and f6 comes with check and
after queen captures or rather rook
captures doesn't really matter just
bishop captures on b7 you attack the
rook if the rook moves you pick up the
a6 pawn if rook to a7 now just queen
captures on d4 you attack the rook on f6
the bishop and queen battery are now
going after the rook and you can't
really play some like rook f8 you just
get checkmated so you kind of have to
trade here queen captures bishop
captures again the rook is hanging and
after the rook moves you're just going
to play bishop to f3 and remarkable
about this position is that the material
is completely even
but black is completely busted uh what
do you play here with black you have one
useful move rook d8 and after rook after
d1 you have no more moves for black here
uh you can't move the knight the rook
would hang you you can't really move the
rook anywhere otherwise rook captures on
c7 and even if you wanted to give up the
pawn there's really nowhere to move that
rook so there is no good move here for
uh for black and white can improve the
position as much as white wants and it's
going to be an easy win for alireza uh
so in case you guys were wondering and
like it's a bliss game so even if they
calculated everything out and you know
they just
i would see it's equal material but now
that of course um yeah you see it and
our good friend the engine confirms it
uh you know you you can push d4 here but
okay in the game knight the b3 was
played rook 8 to d8 now trying to pile
up on that uh weak d3 pawn and now just
knight to c5 putting pressure on the
bishop here so bishop back to c8 also
defending the b7 pawn and rook to e1 now
uh we have h6 bion and queen to c2 uh we
have a5 trying to mess up the the pawn
structure here b captures on a5 knight
captures on a5 and now alireza finally
executes d4 and uh if
you could capture this and keep your
position you'd be okay with this but the
problem is if you capture uh again pawn
to e5 just ruins all of your plans as it
will align the queen with the rook if
bishop otherwise you're just gonna lose
a piece so bishop captures knight
captures queen captures and now the
spectacular bishop to g4 and the the
winning of the e6 square
combined with the queen's access to the
g6 square is just game over for black
for example queen moves somewhere you're
gonna play knight e6 you're going to
attack both of the rooks uh there's
this is resigns for black especially if
bishop captures then you play rook
capture so you completely win the g6
square and black
can just resign here so after d4 uh jan
decided to go knight to c6 instead added
another a defender to the e5 pawn and
now just a d5 already decides that all
right we're not going to push this
uh you know do anything reckless uh
let's uh win this positionally so d5 97
and now just knight to d3 now alireza
says yes i did have a weak d3 pawn for
the entire game but your c7 pawn is
where the position will be decided and
also your e5 pawn is very very weak so
here jan tries to do something he plays
c6 but the position is uh very much
resignable just the captures on c6 and
now you can't react to this because also
the e5 pawn would hang so here we have
bishop to e6 trying something and not
knight d captures on e5 we have b
captures on c6 and now just bishop to d4
going after the undefended knight on b6
we have queen to c7 defending that
knight and now knight captures on c6
this is a it's hard to see uh you know
everything that alireza can capture but
he can capture pretty much anything and
black's position is just falling apart
so bishop captures on d4 was played
knight f captures on d for now rook to
d6 and here pawn to e5 attacking the
rook uh and um
there really isn't all that much you can
do now rook captures and c6 was played
if you don't do this if you play
something like rook to d7 just knight
captures an e7 and uh again
too much material loss will
uh will occur queen to g6 check wink
rook captures on c7
uh
there's really nothing good here or even
if rook to here you can play queen
captures an e6 would check and if queen
to f7 you will save your queen but then
queen captures on b6 it's just uh i mean
this
it's hard to look at so rook captures on
c6 uh by nipple knight captures in c6
and now we have knight to f5 uh trying
to keep the queen out of the out of the
king's lair and now queen the c5 just
improving the position of his pieces
king g7 now comes knight to d4 a nice
finishing touch ballet
saying that if you cap from my queen i
first captured the bishop with a nice
beautiful royal royal fork here
and after the king moves just knife
captures on c5 of course you are down a
full rook so this is uh unplayable so
queen d7 was played but now this also
means that the knight on b6 will hang
of course
alireza will not take it right away to
allow something like queen captures or
knight captures all it is just placed
knight captures on f5 with check and it
was in this position on move 33 that
yanni palmishi resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
now once the
the knight is captured by the bishop or
by the rook doesn't really matter you're
just going to play queen captures on b6
and now if you count the pieces there's
a queen on both sides bishop on both
sides are rooked on both sides but
there's also an extra rook okay let's
make it a green one uh for alireza so
okay this is resigns
uh so after this wonderful knight
captures on f5 uh jan resigned and
alireza takes the win uh in the blitz
section we'll see if jan will be able to
retaliate uh
tomorrow in the second day of the blitz
but for now uh alireza continues very
strong as he was the leader after three
days of rapid alongside maxime bashir
lagrave but he also now wins starts
winning in blitz uh so yeah this is the
first game that i decided to show you
guys are more than welcome to use
hashtag suggestion as this is blitz i
will try to show as many as possible uh
so let's uh let's make them uh the good
ones
i would like to thank damon targaryen
gary sharma as amy and parsons uzi
shaliv and kurosha uh
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the st louis rapid and blitz
event until it finishes uh so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and i am
interested if any of you guys started
watching house of the dragon i was a big
fan of the previous series also i only
read the first book uh but uh i i did
enjoy the series uh
uh until you know uh
that moment where they ran out of book
material but uh i'm wondering if you
guys are now interested in house of the
dragon as well i watched the first two
episodes i'm not going to say anything
but
i'm just interested in your opinion
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it see you soon